so this past Friday just about every
single corporate media outlet
uncritically repeated obviously false
unemployment headlines which Donald
Trump then used to claim everything's
going great in the economy despite us
still being in the middle of the largest
jobs downturn in a very very long time
with historically high unemployment
rates now the the crazy thing about this
is I told you guys this was going to
happen just two weeks ago if you listen
to this podcast if you watch the YouTube
clip I did a story called you're about
to get slammed with garbage math and in
that story I specifically said when the
economy starts to recover you are going
to get hit with growth rates that will
be based on the absolute bottom of this
disaster so I gave the example air
travel dropped ninety-six percent and
then you saw a headline air travel up a
hundred and twenty percent well okay
from the decreased by ninety six percent
number it has doubled and I told you it
would happen with GDP I told you it
would happen with jobs numbers and it
took only two weeks and we're now seeing
it but it's actually even worse because
it's based on admittedly incorrect
numbers from the Bureau of Labor
Statistics not only are they lying in
exactly the way that I predicted they
would be lying they aren't even
reporting what's actually in the BLS
jobs report and this is so important
that everybody understand so all day
Friday Trump and corporate media were
reporting unemployment rate way down to
13.3% two point five million jobs
created the report says in it that
because of what's called a Mis
classification error the unemployment
rate has been reported three months in a
row as being lower than it actually is
and was this was reported by almost no
corporate me
and we're going to show you the actual
numbers and one report from corporate
media that actually looked to get it
right but it was sort of like swept
under the rug so for context remember I
want a recovery I want coronavirus to
end I want the economy to recover
I never wanted anybody to die from
coronavirus I don't want a crappy
economy or death in order to hurt Donald
Trump and his re-election chances that's
an allegation that people like Donald
Trump jr. have made it's ridiculous okay
but we have to tell the truth and the
truth is not being told so let's get
right into the numbers back in April the
unemployment rate of 15 percent was
reported fourteen point seven percent
due to what's called the classification
error the real rate was 19% now for May
we just got the main numbers they are
saying the unemployment rate is 13.3%
while the actual rate is really sixteen
point three percent now to be totally
clear and honest this is still an
improvement from April to May and this
is still the worst unemployment we've
ever had dating back to 1948 when the
numbers started being tracked the way
that they are today so what the hell
happened here what happened is that
employees who should be considered
temporarily unemployed which does count
towards the unemployment rate were
instead classified as absent from work
for other reasons temporarily unemployed
counts towards the unemployment rate
that we know is the u3 that's the rate
that we're talking about here if you're
absent from work for other reasons it
does not count towards the unemployment
rate now usually absent for other
reasons would be something like you're
on a vacation or you're on extended jury
duty you're taking care of a child or
relative that's very different then your
business is closed and you are
unemployed even if the idea is you're
going to go back to work when that
business reopens for some reason and we
really don't know what I'm not implying
that Trump tinkered with the data they
were very conspiratorial claims about
Trump forced the hand of the Bureau of
Labor Statistics that it's a
huge organization and absent evidence of
that I think it would be irresponsible
to suggest Trump demanded fake numbers
be published because they did publish
the real numbers they were just in a
footnote for some reason people who
should have been counted in the
unemployment rate in April and May were
counted as this other category which
artificially lowers the unemployment
rate the report says this happened due
to coronavirus related business closures
as unemployed on temporary layoffs
however it is apparent that not all such
workers were so classified they claimed
to be investigating why the MIS
classification error continues to occur
so this has now happened three times in
March the real unemployment rate was
five point four they reported four point
four in April the real unemployment rate
was nineteen point seven they reported
fourteen point seven and in May the new
numbers the real unemployment rate is
sixteen point three they reported
thirteen point three so understand that
from this same error we now have three
months of headlines that are wrong
almost exclusively reported in the
incorrect form by corporate media I
found one instance of this being
mentioned on Friday here's Steve Rattner
on MSNBC who actually said hey you know
what the there's different numbers there
that are at the actual numbers take a
look through this what I think we are
those of us or into these weeds are
finding is there is a note in the BLS
report today that has to do with
methodology specifically relating to the
Cova problem and I won't get into all
the weeds on that but it but BLS is
noting that that issue has a three
percentage point in fact on unemployment
and that and so that a number of
economists are thinking that the right
number to be looking at it's more like
sixteen percent or sixteen point three
percent now again understand I am not
blaming Trump it is true that a bunch of
jobs were created in May or at least
rehabilitated jobs that's a good thing
but the unemployment rate is still a
record high of more than sixteen point
three percent the Trump administration
has been going crazy with
the economists were wrong well
unemployment was expected to hit 20% at
its peak and it hit 19.7 in April they
just didn't report that number except in
a little footnote they reported it as
14.7 so the bragging about we know
what's actually going on the economists
don't know they predicted 20 they were
way off it's all been been predicted
accurately and I'm the first to tell you
that economists are notably bad at
making economic predictions but none of
this matters the Trump administration
has not only been touting these
incorrect numbers for four days now
they've already created campaign ads
around these incorrectly reported
numbers the jobs report says
unemployment is sixteen point three
percent we've never had anything this
high short of last month and they are
claiming victory and saying let's
reelect Trump based on these record
disaster unemployment numbers they're
living in a fantasy world and I fear
that it is going to work and we're going
to talk about this a little more later
on in the program if you love feeding
your intellectual curiosity but you're
always struggling to find the time check
out one of my all-time favorite apps
called blinka stinketh lets you consume
an entire book on your way home from
work
they take thousands of popular
non-fiction books condense each one into
text or audio that you can get through
in just 15 minutes and you get all of
the important core ideas and information
from that book it's perfect if you don't
have enough time to do all the reading
you want to do or if you just want to
sample a book before you buy the entire
thing I recently read a brief history of
time of course by the great Stephen
Hawking this is a book that I have been
aware of for so long and other things
got in the way and it was fantastic to
check it out on blinkin
blink east has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different nonfiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month and you
the entire library but you can try it
totally free and get 25% off a
subscription when you go to blink is
comm slash Pakman I've put the link
right underneath this video